so praseodymium is a very interesting
element
it's got myriad of uses but perhaps the
most interesting one is that it's been
used to enable us to get within one one
thousandth of a degree of absolute zero
which is minus 273 degrees C which is
pretty darn cold it was just used in the
components which they were using in the
coils to get the temperature down it's
also used in welders goggles because
it's quite good at filtering out harmful
types of light to the human eye so you
find it it's in the goggle and it helps
the world to be able to see what he's
doing it's also been used in a silicate
which has being used to lower the speed
of light down to a mere 300 meters per
second which still pretty fast but not
very fast compared to the normal speed
of light